wie vielen nackten frauen in anzüglichen
posen seit den vergangenen monaten
bewege auf plakatwänden in werbeanzeigen
oder hier im internet sexistische
werbung gibt es auch 2020 noch trotz
aller kritik
sexismus ist eben kein humor und auch
keine meinung sondern sexismus ist
diskriminierung die werbeindustrie wehrt
sich seit jahren gegen jede form der
regulierung erfolgreich und mit
unterstützung der politik also es sind
eben fragen des geschmacks
geschmackserlebnis kugel doch jetzt
nicht hin
in diesem video geht es um eine ganz
einfache frage warum überhaupt gibt es
noch sexistische werbung
die antwort aber ist komplizierter
anfang 2020 ereignet sich auf instagram
etwas ungewöhnliches eine art premiere
und dieser influenza steht im
mittelpunkt von bielecki ist der erste
deutsche influenza der vom deutschen
werberat gerügt wird für dieses foto
er wirbt für ein
nahrungsergänzungsmittel nice schwanz
pro die kapseln sind angeblich ein
libido booster der deutsche werberat
soll über die ethischen grenzen der
werbung machen und trug diese werbung
als herabwürdigend und sexistisch mehr
als ein halbes jahr später ist nichts
passiert die werbung ist noch immer
online und hier beginnt das eigentliche
problem so wütend dass sexismus in der
werbung noch nicht vorbei ist
ich bin maria potthoff ich bin
redaktionsleiterin und moderatorin von
dem funk roma dorfclub auf klo ist ein
feministisches talk format das sich
unter anderem mit sexismus beschäftigt
okay leute die welt ist in aufruhr wie
hat frau sex wenn kein penis involvierte
mut millionen edelstetten pack 1 maria
potthoff macht journalismus auf youtube
und instagram und möchte dass sexismus
hier keine rolle mehr spielt ein post
wie der von ron gajewski ist für sie ein
no go
was nicht okay dass an dieser
darstellung von dieser frau von dem
ersten sätzen des produktes auf dem
hinter anfang dieser frau ist das
einfach die frau in der nicht mächtigen
position ist der typ in der mächtigen
position für das tal typische
darstellung von 1 sexualisierten
frauenkörper sexistische werbung ist
keine geschmackssache sondern eine reale
bedrohung findet maria popp sexistische
werbung stellt die gesellschaft dar und
so witze die unter der gürtellinie sind
wenn die mal eben so schön auf der
großen werbewand vor deinem büro groß
abgebildet sind führen die dazu dass
witze auch im privaten die unter die
gürtellinie gehen verstärkt werden aber
eben auch dass sexualisierte gewalt
klein gehalten wird und still gemacht
wird sexistische werbung wie die von ron
gajewski ärgert sie nicht nur sie
fordert mehr gesellschaftliche kontrolle
besonders alarmierend finde ich nicht
nur den zuspruch denen dieser wirklich
bekannte influenza damit bekommt sondern
alarmierend ist dass der werberat das
nicht verbietet und dass das immer noch
online ist instagram ist superschnell
darin zb apple zu zensieren und damit
ganz accounts oder fotos zu sperren
während so ein video im internet lag und
damit auch eine ganze generation davon
bei
eigentlich soll der deutsche werberat
dafür sorgen dass die werbebranche
ethische standards einhält
das problem die werbebranche
kontrolliert sich selbst und echte
strafen gibt es nicht wer gerückt wird
kann einfach weitermachen sowie ron
beelitz doch das problem ist viel größer
als ein einzelnes sexistisches bild auf
instagram sexistische werbung ist weit
verbreitet
das zeigt eine studie der
frauenrechtsorganisation pilsting
über zwei jahre lang haben sie
bundesweit sexistische werbung gesammelt
per app und mit user beteiligten
wir waren völlig überrascht wir haben
5000 zusendungen bekommen und davon war
wirklich die mehrzahl sexistisch
allerdings nicht wie man denkt auf den
großen bilder soll den großen kampagnen
das heißt dort wo viel geld ausgegeben
wird dass es immer weniger sexismus aber
leider kann man ja heute überführte shop
kann jeder und jede seine werbung selber
gestalten so dass wir gerade im handwerk
und im kleinhandel sehr viel sexistische
werbung haben überall in deutschland
finden wir werbung mit frauen in
halbnackten sexualisierten posen sowie
hier eine werbung für eine lkw
waschanlage
wir wollen von inhaber santos aber
theorie wissen was frauen im bikini
mitautor einigung zu tun haben ist auch
ein schöner blickfang denke ich mal die
stimmen gerade da und waschen ein auto
also ich hab kein bilder gesehen die ein
auto von frauen mit klamotten gewaschen
wohin regeln standen die immer im bikini
also gab es auch keine andere
möglichkeit und deswegen haben also ich
hoffe das bild ausgesucht
ihr könnt von tieren mit der kritik des
werberats die frauen würden auf die
sexuellen reize reduziert und damit
herabgewürdigt sind ja nur zwei frauen
die im bikini ein auto waschen und das
finden die kunden auch ganz schön
und die würden sich sogar freuen wenn
die wirkliche live hier beim waschen
dabei wären
der werberat trübte die reklame und dann
passierte nichts erstmal habe ich
darüber gelacht weil ich finde da ist ja
nichts schlimmes dabei und ich sollte
das abstellen und du ja habe ich aber
erst nicht gemacht weil wie gesagt ich
bin immer noch der meinung dass es nicht
sexistisch ist sandro sabatini ist kein
einzelfall auch in wil sg stört sich
nicht an der rüge des deutschen
werberats warum hat er den post bis
heute nicht gelöscht wollen wir wissen
und kontaktieren rory let's be wie
instagram doch er antwortet nicht
auch das unternehmen rock nutrition will
mit der werbung von ron bielecki nichts
zu tun haben
man sei nicht sein management
komisch dabei wirkt locken mit frischen
noch immer mit ron williams gesicht und
der ceo des unternehmens posiert mit ron
milewski auf instagram über sexistische
werbung wollen die beiden aber nicht mit
uns sprechen und erteilen uns eine
interview absage auf dem gerügten post
sind die beiden aber offenbar ziemlich
stolz und platzieren ihn in einem
goldrahmen
doch nicht nur influenza und
kleinunternehmerinnen lassen sich von
dem ethischen kodex des werberats
mitunter wenig beeindrucken
auch große unternehmen nutzen
provokative kampagnen gezielt um
aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen 2016 sorgte
die true fruits kampagne samen saft für
viele beschwerden der werberat schrieb
dem unternehmen und dessen marketing
chef machte sich über die kritik
öffentlich lustig sehr geehrte sehr
geehrte damen und herren uns erreicht
diese woche bereits das dritte schreiben
des deutschen werberats diese vorgeführt
werden uns schwer und ich bitte alle mal
den die hand zu nehmen die ich bitte
alle mal die hand zu nehmen die sich
dadurch wirklich wirklich weil es den
kühlen
am ende gibt der werberat in unternehmen
recht und sieht von einer beanstandung
ab und schöne flugmarkt weiter mit noch
krasseren kampagne 2009/10 gibt es einen
gewaltigen schritt stone sommer waren
feierst du endlich sein comeback und
comebacks geschrieben mit dem englischen
wort für erkrath der werberat erteilte
fritz eine öffentliche rüge
sowohl das weibliche als auch das
männliche model würden in
herabwürdigender art und weise als
gegenstand sexueller phantasien und
praktiken dargestellt über seine
umstrittenen kampagnen möchte true
fruits mit uns nicht spricht per mail
erklärt ist das ist den werberat gut
finde und die rüge aus dem jahr 2019
anerkenne
verantwortlich für die umstrittenen
kampagne ist marketingchef nicolas le
clou wer lieber von einigen nicht
gemochten dafür von anderen gefeiert als
dass ich öfter bodystyling bin denn
everybody's darling ist everybodys
arschloch
was mich ganz besonders schockiert ist
dass die marketingabteilung von true
fruits ganz genau weiß was sie dort tun
dass sie wissen
das dass sexismus ist und wissen dass
sie damit aufmerksamkeit generieren
können und das unternehmen letztendlich
davon profitiert die meisten unternehmen
reagieren auf die beschwerden des
werberats wenn es darauf ankommt können
unternehmen auch nach einer öffentlichen
rüge weitermachen wie bisher
müsste hier der staat eingreifen ich
sehe wir brauchen ein gesetz weil eben
der werberat doch nicht die
möglichkeiten hat die es bräuchte um
allen linien werden
wir fragen nach beim werberat schärfere
gesetze gegen sexismus stadt
freiwilliger selbstkontrolle der
antwortet nur schriftlich sexy ist nicht
sexistisch und weiter der staat sollte
nicht über ein gesetzliches verbot
regeln welche bilder in der werbung
zeitgemäß sind und deshalb gezeigt
werden dürfen
doch in anderen ländern gibt es bereits
gesetze gegen sexistische werbung in
norwegen schon seit 1978 ein gesetz
gegen werk in deutschland würde zunächst
einmal vor allem rechtssicherheit
bringen müssten alle das ist jetzt
verbunden ist und es wäre klar ist
funktionen in deutschland sollte es 2016
so weit sein
der damalige justizminister heiko maas
wollte mit einem gesetz gegen
sexistische werbung vorgehen dagegen
machte die boulevardpresse und die
werbeindustrie mobil mit politischer
unterstützung unter anderem von ihm fdp
chef christian linken die verhüllung von
frauen zur bändigung von männern zu
fordern das kannte man von radikalen
islamischen religionsführern aber nicht
vom deutschen justizminister im februar
2020 gibt christian lindner sich
überrascht
eine gesetzesinitiative von herrn mas
haben sie lächerlich gemacht vor 34
jahren
ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht was genau
sie meinen sie haben maß mit islamischen
religionsführern verglichen
ja das meinen sie ja jetzt war sie ja
also es sind eben fragen des geschmacks
da sind viele eigenes geschmacks der
länderkammer hinein ich gucke da jetzt
nicht hin
das ist eine geschmacksfrage das ist
eine frage von menschen oder ist das
nicht frauenverachtend sollte sowas
nicht verboten werden
äußere mich zu allen wo ich in der sache
genauer ahnung auch von der rechtslage
habe hier das ist ein thema für unsere
rechtspolitik um die gesetzesinitiative
scheiterte zu groß war der widerstand
auch aus der werbebranche
stattdessen gab das
bundesfamilienministerium eine studie in
auftrag bei pink things für 400.000 euro
seit vergangenem oktober liegen die
ergebnisse vor
seit monaten ohne jede reaktion aus der
politik das sind 400.000 euro die uns
gegeben wurden führt zwei jahre um diese
studie zu machen und jetzt interessiert
sie niemanden deswegen überhaupt keine
rückmeldung von den politiker innen
bekommen die das eigentliche studie
beauftragt haben dass es eigentlich
nicht fair den steuerzahler innen
gegenüber sexismus in der werbung belegt
durch ein teures monitoring und die
frauenministerin zeigt kein interesse
eine gesetzesreform lehnen sie ab auch
haben sie bis heute nicht reagiert auf
das monitoring sagt springsteen 400.000
euro hat sie gekostet warum reagieren
sie nicht
geisterspiel von welchem monitoring- sie
jetzt da gerade sprechen
sexistische werbung mit dem monitoring
was 4000 euro gekostet hat von ihrem
ministerium in auftrag gegeben sie mir
im detail noch mal ansehen was ist dann
mit außenseite und wir können da gerne
auch noch mal im detail darüber sprechen
aber ich würde gerne bevor ich jetzt
hier
dieses versprechen gab franziska giffey
ende februar
doch bis heute hat sich das ministerium
nicht mehr bei ping things gemeldet um
über die 400.000 euro teure sexismus
studie zu reden
stattdessen heißt es jetzt in einer e
mail zitat politik allein kann hier
nicht alles richten
das ministerium sieht hier auch die
wirtschaft in der pflicht sich dem thema
zu stellen
sexismus muss als das bezeichnet werden
was er ist nämlich eine form von gewalt
sollte das ziel der politik und unserer
gesellschaft sein sexistische werbung
abzuschaffen und gegen sexismus
vorzugehen und nicht nur ist das wichtig
weil sexualisierte gewalt besonders für
frauen in unserer gesellschaft ein
riesiges problem darstellen sondern auch
männer würden davon profitieren wenn sie
nicht die sagt immer mächtigen immer
starken erwartungshaltung gerecht werden
wie sehr ärgert euch sexistische werbung
schreibt es uns in die kommentare
[Musik]
[Applaus]